welcome to episode 351 of uh this past
weekend thank you
for being alive at this time
and i'm happy to be alive for the most
part and i'm happy to be here with you
that part is definite and um
what's going on man i'm dealing with a
lot of uh
itchery at the house i got you know i
got a bad detergent
i don't want to call out any shops or
mercantiles but
um 99 cent store
you know y'all gave me some they gave me
some tide
and it's i think tied fresh and easy
i think it's the packaging let me
be sure of that i don't want to send
somebody on a bad route here
tied fresh
and clean is the item i'm talking about
and i don't know if they just got a hot
batch or something but it's got it's got
me itching
everything and at first i didn't know
what was happening
i didn't know you could have asked me
what's happening i said
look i don't you know i don't know i
don't know
and i was seeing kind of whelps around
my ankles
you know when i got a little bit of fat
family and uh
sometimes a lot of sugar will gather
around your ankles down in your blood
you know ankles just that that's that
hearty swamp knuckle that's that last
hitter
when you really get down to the ankle
that's really
i mean damn that's the lord's u-turn at
each one of your legs
you know that's where the stream kind of
stops and rebuttals
so a lot of you know like i said i got
family that's real
got a lot of grits in them if you know
what i'm saying and uh
you know they real you know they hearty
they hearty you crack them up and they
gonna have a couple hearts in them man
you know they hearty and uh and so the
deal is that
a lot of sugar gathers air at that
little turnabout at the ankle
so anyway i'm thinking maybe i'm you
know i've had some bad uh
chamomile tea or i've had a bad donut or
something
you know maybe i had me a couple you
know i put a little
you know i like ribs i like rib meat and
sometime i put a little too much sauce
on there
so really i'm having sauce and i'm just
eating it with a rib
you know at some point i'm i'm the
entree is the sauce so i've been there
you know sometime at a barbecue you'll
see me sitting at that last uh
at the last picnic tables and i'm just
dipping a bone in the sauce you know
i'm just going with straight marrow to
mouth honey you know
i'm just hauling sauce man so
um so i thought maybe i'd had too much
sugar i'd had too much barbecue sauce or
it was a condiment that was real
sweet heavy that was making me have too
much sugar in my body making my ankles
itch
and so i'm trying to adjust my diet and
i keep itching and then
i saw a spider
and so i said oh damn you know
charlotte's webbing this [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying this
this that damn fifth grade reading level
that shit's
you know causing me to act up
and then i noticed all my dermis on my
legs and um
kind of the top of my ass really are i
don't know what that's called at the top
here
where your ass kind of meets your back
that part started getting bumps a little
wet uh
welts on it or something i said what's
going on
i thought i was getting bit by spiders
so i slept in a different bed
you know i got me a batch of spider
traps off the internet
and one company i bought them from some
chinese company i
finally opened up the spider trap
because i was kept itching
day after day open up there's nothing in
that [ __ ]
so they're selling out here selling fake
spider traps out here
damn gary v out here whoever it is
out here selling him frank you know them
fake ass arachnid apartments and
you know i'm thinking these they're out
here
gripping these uh these little climbers
and nothing
and there's nothing you know open four
i'm up there's nothing in that [ __ ] no
poison nothing
hell i could have licked my fingers
after and i'd have been fine so
so anyway just a couple bad purchases uh
so i finally i realized well
um it's maybe it's the detergent
and what you don't understand is when
you when you when your detergent
is uh faulty or whatever
um or you're allergic to it you have an
allergen allergen
when you have allergen then
everything you you don't realize how
many things have
touched your detergent
your socks pants
pillowcases sheets towels that was the
one that i kept
you know i'd dry off i bought some
clothes
i went to target bought me a damn batch
of haynes over there
everything top to bottom i mean damn
foot to uh to front piece you know just
hanged up i mean i look like a damn
stunt double on a michael jordan
commercial you know i was just hanging
in the membrane baby you know what i'm
saying we hanged out
they see me hanging they hating
you know what i'm saying i was real
hanged up and uh
and damn uh
but you don't realize the towel when you
get out the tub you're drying yourself
with the bad detergent
so anyway man i'm at a place right now
i'm having to re-wash everything in my
place
with some damn non-allergen
you know you know real tender detergent
no homo bruh no bromo no nothing
you know everything's normal and uh
so we got the regular detergent now or
something soft
soft batch baby something you could damn
i mean [ __ ] you give half a cup of this
to a damn toddler i bet
and he'd be fine i don't think there's
even a medical warning on the back of it
so you know i'm upstairs but i'm damn
i'm itching i'm itching while i'm up
there i'm still recovering i'll include
a couple
photos and images right here right now
of the whelps and just little
you just don't realize how much of your
body is uh
touches detergent or when you hug
somebody i dated a gal in college
for a little bit and her name was i'm
not gonna say her name but it was uh
vanessa was her name
and they called her van and i don't
you know i don't i don't recommend
dating women name
after uh autos
you know and but anyway i dated this gal
van and she was a real
stocky she was stocky you know what i'm
saying she would damn
she could kind of flex and make her
breasts real hard if you want you know
what i'm saying if you were into that
kind of [ __ ]
and i guess i don't know if i was into
that but i was
you know she she was willing to date me
and so there i was
but anyway what i'm trying to tell you
is and i remember when she would hug me
the detergent they used was bad
so i remember after we get done making
out or doing sex or
anything like that i'd look like a damn
you know
i'd look like i'd just been in a gang
bang with a damn anteater
you know and he'd been breathing out the
whole time
so
oh whatever man but anyway i'm happy to
be here today with you i really am and
and i'm happy to be alive and i'm happy
that you're alive and that's where i'm
at
so i just i wanted to come to you
cleanly and let you know where i'm at
today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza
1811 pico boulevard on the way to the
beach
in los angeles grey block get that
hitter
all right let's uh let's see what we're
capable of
[Music]
come on baby
that throwback hitter baby
[Music]
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i
be so far from my home
tell them travis and my mind is
somewhere
else but when i find it i'll patch up
where
it's been blown come on
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of
[Music]
closed captioning
and that is bishop gunn right there
and that band they they they discontin
they they couldn't keep it together
you know things happen you know a band
is just a family
that has a skill set
and just like families you know people
get you know somebody's huffing gas
somebody's
you know too big for their britches
somebody's too small for their britches
like my buddy allen i grew up with
you know he i mean he could barely fit
into a damn uh
child you know he he could barely fit
into a child's pant
praise god brother um
what's going on i'm here you're here and
uh
and we are doing it we're heading into
the fall
and that's a lie actually because it's
august is really that last
gas baby it's that fifth round
of the summer it's that you know it's
that fifth and final
round of the summer um
what have i been doing man we had a
great episode with uh
with john crist if you're not familiar
if you're not familiar with john you
know he's an interesting
he's an interesting guy
you know he talked about growing up in a
a household they had eight children i
mean damn i you know
you could run into somebody in the hall
and barely [ __ ] remember who they
are what are you ronald no i'm not
ronald
you know i'm diana well damn you know
grow your hair out
you know eight people i mean it's and he
said they made you take your shoes off
at his house when you got there
all fair he and i were chatting he said
that they had to take their shoes off at
the door
and i'm thinking well sometimes you get
back to the door and you did
there's damn 16 shoes there and that's
just the children [ __ ] you can put on
two shoes
any type
you know you you're sitting there at
church with a damn sandal and a boot on
and you think you did well it just
you could me you could meet somebody
that that you think is cute or has
attraction
you know visuality really hits your eyes
and you like it
and they could be family and that's
something that's just normal some of
that's
you get outside of eight i think
anything after seven children man i
don't know i don't
i would never promote incestuality
and i never have you could look at any
chart or any
you know history log
you could look at my damn google log
i've never even looked it up
i guarantee you i would um misspell it
but i think anything outside after seven
kids man somebody should be allowed to
date
if you got two kids and you're trying to
date that's dude that's dicey
you know what i'm saying you gotta
tighten up man you gotta you know get on
the apps or something
but if you have over seven children and
two of them start you know
at least high fiving each other or
playing this game a lot you know and
really you know
and doing it real heavy uh or late at
night then
i think you gotta you gotta let that
slide
you know but what do i know
um anyway what are we talking about man
uh
what did i do this weekend well i just
got out of my ice plunge
and i've been in there and um you know
the fella that owns grey block pizza
my friend thomas he make ice plunges now
it's a separate company and uh they sent
me one of them
and i'll put a video on the clips
channel of my first couple times in
there
and it's real interesting because it
makes your
body feel almost makes your body feel
like it disappears it's so
chilled out that just your head is awake
you know you can't really feel a pinch
or
you know a small dog could bite you a
damn
not a german shepherd but like a french
shepherd
could bite you you wouldn't even feel it
you know you just wouldn't have that
you wouldn't know so because your body
real chilled out but uh
so i've been in that um
you know i've been dealing with the
detergent issue
and i'm not you know i just will not use
the brand anymore tied fresh and easy
it ain't easy brother it might be fresh
but it's
you know it's one for two as far as i'm
concerned praise god brother ptl
you know that i'm upstairs
i'll tell you this i watched the fight
oh
i watched the fight this weekend and i'm
going to go on
look corey sandhagen
versus uh tuja dillashaw
and
look these men are both warriors
you know i i
am not anything like them i
am you know these these are first
class combatists
you know these men have i mean and i you
know
i've suffered from erectile dysfunction
you know these dudes have you know
i mean they're just damn made out of
viagra it almost seemed like they'll
just
i mean they'll just damn put your lights
out
they got almost like dicks in their arms
you know they're just so
uh virile you know they're warriors the
combatants
um if it were
you know archaic times or robin hood
whenever that was 1600
you know you'd have san hagen would be
like a he'd be a king or a young king
somewhere
and i think uh tuja would be a uh
he'd be a you know uh
he almost has the villain role to me for
some reason
and i don't know why that is maybe it
could have been his
you know because of the suspension
coming back from the suspension he had
that
you know he's got that um
[Music]
that's uh he's a little more slytherin
and i'm not you know no shade either of
these men they're both
you know these men would i mean these
men could tie me in a knot with their
damn tongue
you know these fellas would cherry stand
me up
so uh but anyway i'm watching the fight
and
i mean san hagen put that he put he he
hit him in the rafters real early
you know and he he really clipped him
and got a little bit of blood out of
them
not much but i would say probably half
cup
throughout the whole event quarter cup
maybe
um which might have given you the the
but maybe if you're if if i'm corey san
hagen i have the idea that i'm getting
maybe it gives me the idea that i'm
winning more that i'm it just
visually it looked like that so i could
know that maybe that would have been off
you had you had um san hagen landed more
strikes you know he hit him with more
opportunities i mean he was just damn
throwing just you know he was out there
like a damn battle bot
now i think the part where it gets
tricky
is that dillashaw is that pressure bear
you know what i'm saying he's that honey
hunter man he's
the second you let him
the second you open that zoo cage he is
out there mauling people
whereas san hagen is more that sniper
you know he kind of works for the
electric company he'll climb up the pole
and kind of see what's going on and then
he'll
zap you you know
he's really that um you know that's kind
of how he is you know
uh but damn dillashaw's out there
beating the damn uh
diet coke out of a child's hand he don't
you know what i'm saying he's just
he's the mauler so i think
i could see it visually there's kind of
two different things going on you have
dillashaw controlling
you know we kind of held corey against
the cage he had that control time
you know that time of it was almost slow
dancing almost want him to put a song on
you know put on some garth brooks or put
on a little bit of uh
you know maybe some really slow kodak
black or something if he's ever done a
ballad
or some early uh
or some early some early jb
you know throw that on but the controls
are like it's just kind of like
i don't know i feel like sometimes
you're just holding somebody there
now i know we did a lot of knees to him
he really kneed him up
you know we need him up like a damn you
know kind of like the way an armless man
would make a damn uh
would kind of prepare a doe or do veal
if you got somebody with no arms the way
they do veal it's just
you know what i'm saying they need that
damn little animal in a submission
until it's ready to you know be a damn
macaroni grill entree
but i just feel like and and so
you had san hagen uh you had dillashaw
pushed the bout
he pushed about he came at him but i
don't think there's anything wrong with
backing away from a guy to get into the
position that you want the most
you know if a bee's coming at you
you don't just attack the beat you kind
of reposition yourself
you move around you might circle the
block
you may put a mannequin out there that's
dressed like you and then
sneak around watch the bee see what it's
doing and then come back
at it but
i don't think there's anything wrong
with just reposition yourself if you
look at how what sandy hagan did
against uh frankie edgar's who i love
dear god man i wish he was my godfather
if i could be
you know if i could climb back in my
mother's vagina and you know email
frankie before i would see if he would
do that for me
but san hagen did that against edgar he
kind of just backed up and moved him
into position
so you have to respect that just because
a guy is kind of retreating
that can be strategy
so i thought it was really close um
[Music]
i think it's interesting when a sport is
also a business
there's gonna become moments where if
you let it be too close
that the business can
help determine what the future looks
like
and it's a great look for the uh weight
class it's a great look for
ufc um
you know dillashaw was
you know they kind of it almost felt
like
san hagan had to prove himself more than
dillashaw had to prove himself
so i don't know if some of the judges
went into it with uh you know with that
sort of
mindset in the beginning but i feel like
the outcome was better for the business
and also look what do i know nothing i'm
a one stripe white belt that hasn't been
in class in almost a month because i
my ribs kept getting fractured by women
and men and women
but um so i think that it was a great
it looks it's great for the business
suddenly you got dylan shaw's back in
there and
uh you know he's back in the in the bout
structure
so you're going to get more fights out
of him san hagen's still young you know
he can you know
he'll be able to meander around in there
before uh
you know he'll be able to you know you
could
insert him back in for that title shot
whenever
maybe you run it back um
i don't know i just don't see i see how
if i'm the business
if i'm the business i i then i give it
to dylan shaw
but if i'm a judge i side with how
anthony smith said it you know
the lionhearted one he said it after the
show he said
i had it 4-1 uh san hagen's
and that's how i had it man i had sand
higgins winning
now brennan and child would disagree
with me but
oh well i don't have to agree with him
all the time if i don't want to
or anyone and look i don't know what i'm
talking about
but i believe i know what i saw
and i believe that corey sanhagan did
enough to win
so what else man what else do we have
going on out here in the world uh
i what else did i do
yeah that john chris episode is just
it's a good one
you know we talked a lot about sex
addiction
and just why
we kind of what
young men or how our early lives shape
how we interact with affection
as we grow older
um and john was really forthright
talking about his journey and his
struggles and
and sometimes you know we get in the
struggle space where it's like
once you enter the struggle space you
you kind of think everything is a
struggle
and i recognize that you know
sometimes things just are what they are
it's not necessarily a struggle it's not
necessarily
a uh um
a bonus or a
a bravado or a positive it's just is
what it is
um but it was interesting man we talked
about
the first time you ever eject out of
your body
the first time you let that you know you
let god's trout just kind of fly to your
body out of you
out of your body
and what that was like and the feeling
from it
you know i think i felt real ashamed the
first time i really just sprayed out
i felt a shame man
i felt excited and fired up i felt like
i had
it's almost like your thumb wrestling
and you really win against yourself and
one of your thumbs is
you know your opinion is your wiener
body wiener
you know i remember being young and i
found some liquor and some
uh titty mags you know titty
you know literature titty literature
and i was up on this shelving unit i
climbed up there and found me a little
the little jack stack you know my
brother had something
and he'd been touching himself and i
didn't know it
and i shouldn't know it there's only you
know we had four children now if we got
up to seven children
then maybe we could have started writing
a little note leaving notes for each
other but we was at four children
in our household
and i just remember pleasuring myself
and then
i'd been drinking he had a little bit of
liquor up there cisco
uh strawberry dazzle or something
and it was herb and liquor a lot of you
see a lot of brothers sipping on it
you know older men older older kind of
darker men you'd see them sucking on a
bottle of it over there by the amp
or behind the post office
and i had that and i lipped down i gum
down two sips of that and next thing you
know i'm pleasuring myself
you know when the lord's neosporin is
just flowing right out of my damn
nuts
and i remember feeling
i mean i felt exalted i felt excited i
felt
but i also remember this feeling kind of
shame because you had to go and clean it
off my body i had to clean it off of me
and i think i felt a lot of shame i
think
because it really it's a precious metal
man there's no more precious metal
than pure body semen
i don't think and what do i know
you know what i'm saying i'm just an
adult
but there's no more precious i mean i've
always long
said that it should be on the uh
it should be on the periodic table you
know it's that liquid life i can't
believe
carbon is on there uh
let me look up a periodic element
periodic
element
let me rattle off a couple that are on
here
damn uh
laurencium who the hell is that
laurencium's on that [ __ ] dubbed him
come on man dubbed him and see him at
semenium on
and on here osmium
iridium dude he played basketball at our
high school
iridium bayham dude come on
so i'm just saying if anything should be
on a periodic table element should be
semen brother
body semen and that's a fact brother
i mean that's an adult fact so
but anyway if you have a story about if
you want to share about the first time
you ever busted out of your body first
time you ever
you know you really just are you're
taking everything that's in you that's
possible
and just sharing that into the world did
you feel okay do you feel
bad you know the uh
hit the hotline 985-664-9503
and i'm coming off a rough patch too
i've been
you know i masturbated last night
and so i think i'm feeling
some type of way
and it was the second night in a row for
me
so that's who i am right now
and that's okay i still got up and
stayed active this morning
i plan on eating lunch i'm taking care
of myself but
riley mal what do you think
i'm joking he's not here would it matter
if he was here
this would be his answer
of course um
what else do we have going on we got um
yeah if you have a story about that
first bust man that time you brought it
into the world
because once you you know once you uh
once you really crack open that cavern
it's hard to go back
it's hard to roll that rock in front of
that
you know in front of this new
chasm or chasm that you've
created in the world it's hard to close
pandora's box man
you got that spunk stick on you you know
you got that little fiddle man and you
know how to play it
you got that i want to feel good now
little handle on you
and that's weiner baby that's body
weiner
i want to tell you about this right now
that
mint mobile is something that is good
they offer premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month
you know i thought what's the catch but
after speaking
with the good people at meant mobile and
using their service it all made sense
there isn't one mint mobile's secret
sauce is that they're the first company
to sell wireless service online only
by cutting out retail stores there's no
crazy overhead cost
so you know a lot of mobile you know
they
you got to have this shop and you got to
have this mint mobile cuts corners
you know they cut out the store there's
no overhead cost they just ship it to
you man for people looking for extra
savings mint mobile offers premium
wireless
15 a month jeepers
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network
so they're renting out a deal with a 5g
network and they're offering it to you
without the shop
without that middle man if you're not
100 satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day money back guarantee
to get what you might need a new
wireless plan for this 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mint mobile.com t-h-e-o
that's mint mobile.com theo cut your
wireless bill to 15
bucks a month mintmobile.com
[Music]
theo you know a lot of people aren't
working right now and
hell it's pissing a lot of people off
you go to i went to home depot
nobody back in the garden jesus i felt
like adam back there
you know i could have eaten an apple and
damn master you know i could have done
whatever
i wanted touch some titty back there if
i brought something with me
but you know just different you just you
know
nobody's back there jeepers i could have
unleashed a snake and hit an apple back
there and damn re-enacted the bible if i
wanted to
praise god brother but
everyone knows when you're applying to
jobs you're lucky if you make it through
one application before you're ready to
give up
that's true you're writing this male
female
non-binary no crotch you know
no crotch no homo no uh
no nothing you know ghost that's gonna
be an option soon
well the ladders new apply for me
service
is a game changer it's a number one job
search site
for six figure jobs if you want that big
job they can help you do it with your
membership you can easily search
thousands of jobs and get in front of
top recruiters
and their apply for me service takes all
the work of applying for jobs off your
hands
all you do is click apply for me and the
latter's team will fill out all the
forms for you
they'll send you an email confirmation
when your application is complete
sit back relax and with the new google
chrome extension apply for me works on
any job site
just one click no hassle just go to
the ladders l-a-d-d-e-r-s dot com
slash t-h-e-o to sign up that's the
ladders l-a-d-d-e-r-s dot com slash
theo to sign up today
and i'm enjoying me a liquid death right
there man
yeah hit the hotline if you have a good
story about how you
you know or just what you felt like the
first time you really
made pleasant with yourself
first time you ever really kind of took
your little wiener on a date with your
hand
when you did that dirty dance with that
poem
when you made it you know made a little
batch of palm salad
you know what i'm saying tell us about
that
985-664-9503 is the hotline
and as always bless everybody praise god
um what else man we had some great calls
that came in
and some great videos i want to
introduce you first so to a couple
fellows i'm really enamored with
and you're gonna see these fellas right
here and these fellas have down syndrome
and some of you may not believe in down
syndrome i'm not here to debate that
you know i beat it when i was young and
they said
the doctor in our town dr henry
he said i beat it and so i've always
felt indebted to the
community i've always
you know when a lot of people with that
have ds will see me they know
they i think they know i'm one of those
cusp riders you know
that i have it in me
to be very similar to them and if you
haven't seen these fellas on uh
on tick-tock this is uh called get down
with
s m and s
m is a different it's not like sexual
this is uh
down syndrome cooking let's chime in one
time beautiful young men too and i think
they're brothers
or cousins maybe you do some
chickens
first you've got some this
and you can see the fellas are right
here they're putting uh
chives or something on a cutlet
and my god it's beautiful man they're in
a nice kitchen if you haven't seen two
and they're asian fellas too a little
couple little bobby lee's if you haven't
seen a couple ds out bobby lee's put
chives on a uh
on a cutlet man you're missing out and
these fellas are beautiful
and one of them smelled his hand at the
end and that's a
that's nature baby and here's one right
here
oh when they licking the uh the little
rudders the
um they're licking the cake batter
spinners remember mom used to have that
thing she would fold it back and put
those two little spannered
little dragon arms in the deal and then
they she
turn it off wow
i don't know what it is it's too
beaters beaters and you can see these
fella licking the beaters man
a couple beautiful little bobby lee's
over here licking these beaters couple
stevie lees man and these guys are
they're pretty jacked obviously these
guys are on pre-workout or something
and these guys are beautiful handsome
guys
and uh they also have down syndrome but
they're cooking
and so it's just beautiful to see what
you could do with different uh
you know if you have if you're missing a
couple you know a little bit of your
municipalities how you can still make a
hors d'oeuvre or do something beautiful
and do a dessert
[Music]
oh yeah little danny going in on his be
on his beater man he looked that thing
about 15 times baby heavy
he real tongue heavy oh marley is one of
his names shawn and marley
oh yeah oh he put the whole thing in his
mouth at the end
whoa whoa whoa man and that's really you
gotta have eight children to be doing
that kind of thing at the house bubba
but hey
it's real fearless man you know it's
real fearless so if you want to see some
good cooking with those beautiful guys
shawn and marley on tick-tock
and i ended up in the down syndrome and
in the uh autism
cycle a lot of things that get put into
my tick-tock i'm in that algorithm
so that's where i'm at you know what i'm
saying i'm upstairs
baby praise god man we'll watch one more
where they wash their hands it really is
real cute
early
[Music]
oh he said he needs a hand with the uh
with the falafel mix and shawn is uh
went to wash his hands so they have some
miscommunication
[ __ ] that was the hate yeah not wash
your hands sean
don't do it okay beautiful right there
man that's awesome
good to see that man what else we got uh
another video was sent in here that's a
tick-tock a
fight on spirit airlines let's go
uh-oh no
don't do that she trying to bring
somebody with him
[Applause]
to urban women and they like to fight
you know that and they're out here about
to get at it
there they go oh it's lit
it's lit it's lit
it's lit
some fella got in a lot of hair pulling
a lot of ass a lot of thick ass being
[Music]
she didn't put her
and there you go right there and this
kind of stuff i mean
uh this the kind of [ __ ] it's like when
does it end
you know why people can't figure out how
to be okay
in society you know
and this is all too common black people
love to fight
in kind of like
outside the ring i feel like
you know black people are not afraid to
fight anywhere that's
really what i'm saying they'll fight
wherever
i think other cultures mexican people
they fight more like in a car
wash or in a boxing ring
white people i think more fight like in
a courtroom
or sometimes outdoors like on a porch
but spirit airlines really has become
the bellator
of uh
of kind of like for the urban community
in the sky
it's become the bellator of the sky i
think that
um now i look i had to fly spirit one
time god bless man
and i saw two dogs go at it
two people had dogs i don't know if this
was sanctioned or what but then [ __ ]
started throating at each other
praise god man so just stay safe out
there if you're on spirit
i think just wear a jersey wear an
atlanta hawks jersey wear something that
kind of blends in you know uh
but know that
you could be near a scuffle i think
and that's spirit bro amen that's spirit
we had a lot of people calling with
their last words
last episode solo episode excuse me
we talked about what the last words
would be
you know if you had that you know you
want to die somewhere decent so you have
some last words and here's some people
yo theo vine this is benedict from
berlin calling about
last week's podcast last words
benedict from berlin baby thank you for
calling sir
in berlin man that's really that uh
you know berlin is a good place i think
to listen to some damn billy idol and
and spray paint a building baby praise
god let's hear more
i'm a huge uh johnny guitar watson fan
so uh i gotta quote his last words
apparently last
words in tokyo japan
last show he died on stage and his last
words were
ain't that a [ __ ]
amen there you go fresh out of berlin
right there fella hitting us with some
last words ain't that a [ __ ]
i like that ain't that a [ __ ]
because it is man you know life is just
it's just it's another it's a [ __ ]
after a [ __ ] after a [ __ ]
here's a [ __ ] there's a [ __ ] ever
where's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's this [ __ ] this [ __ ] and i'm not
talking feminine i'm talking just
anything you know
a dog bites you you know a bad detergent
gets sold to you
you know somebody you know somebody whip
and weave out on spirit airline you know
it's just
it never ends it's bad [ __ ] central out
there
and that's life it's really just
managing bad [ __ ]
that's all it is so thank you for that
ain't that a [ __ ] here's a couple more
that came in here's one
t-o gang gang this is your boy bamboo
from connecticut and bamboo
and that's a very uh that's a taut wood
baby
you know something like teak is more
malleable
but bamboo out of connecticut and you
obviously your family's got to be either
real rich or real poor to name their
child after a
uh asian forest would i think
good to hear from you boo i was just
calling
about the whole last words deal i know
riley mount was struggling
uh trying to figure out his last words
so
riley mouse struggles to figure out his
first words you know
the fella it's it's tough to see
that asian community is really kind of
they're sputtering it's all
you know everybody's sputtering
really i think i speak for a lot of us
out there i would say
uh my last words uh would be delete my
browser history
you know trying to have my memory intact
as i shade out you know what i mean
thank you bubby okay
gang baby you're right the last thing i
want them to see is uh
you know the naughty things that i've
googled or looked for
you know and it's sad man i mean i got
the blockers on my phone for the
pornography
but i found a loophole through twitter
so i'm out there sometime on per you
know perv city and perv support
and it just oh man the shame the shame
the depletion
just blowing your little you know just
blowing your nut nose
into a little handkerchief or into a dam
and just washing it down the drain dear
god
anyway bamboo i hope you're doing well
out there brother
i hope you're doing well bamboo oh my
neighbor has a dog named bamboo as well
so cool to hear it cool to hear the name
again i like hearing it
bamboo all right let's hear another one
that came in here we go
hey what's up ceo this is ryan down in
south georgia
dennis sojou huh south georgia baby
and it gets a little rural out there it
gets a little interesting you head down
towards jacksonville
you know you see a lot of people down
there getting a little rural
a lot of people you know limited
alphabet you'll see a 20-letter alphabet
down there like damn
you know you show up with a w they don't
know what you're talking about
you show up with an r they they shocked
let's hear more calling about what would
my last words be
yeah you probably have to play on to the
timing but
i'd probably say like i
hit the billion dollars and uh
that's it i'm out cold the whole family
is just left
like dang where's this money at
okay so you tell you you give half a
clue i hid to me i hid this you know
your real father is that would be a good
one if you had children stunt them a
little
your real father
you know i was molested by the postman
something like that
give a clue to something
i like that it's interesting i hid the
million though
if you now if you have a structure of a
life where you your family's gonna
believe that
but if you're living in a four-door
sedan
you know and you accidentally park in a
garage and you keep the
thing on and you know the gas gets you
and you lunged out on that carbon
monoxide
if you're dying from carbon monoxide man
and you tell your kid i hid the million
dollars i'm like you're a [ __ ]
deadbeat the kid's not gonna
fully believe you so you need
believability that's what that one's
missing
let's hear another one the last one here
we go thank you for uh these as well
what up theo this is bo uh calling in
about my last words i think if i'm being
real
realistic it's probably just going to be
[ __ ] you know
on my way out as i get stabbed or shot
you know everyone's gonna just throw out
a [ __ ] and then you're lucky if you get
something else out after that
i don't know what do you think gang baby
i
you know that's interesting because of
cause
sex is what got us into the world
and i would bet you're right i bet eight
out of ten times the last word is [ __ ]
a refu ck i don't want to say it that
much but f-u-c-k
and you know what i'm saying
so that's was the irony of it all it
took somebody doing sex to even get you
to exist
and now you're on your way out and
that's the last thing you're saying
is full circle baby
it's a dirty roundabout
it's that ankle
you flow in you flow out
being alive we got a beautiful single
mom nomination we're going to get to in
just a second i got to let you know that
uh
this summer get the most out of your
travels abroad by learning the language
of your destination with
babel babel babel
the number one selling language learning
app
from ordering in restaurants or asking
for directions
to gaining a deeper understanding of the
culture
babel makes the whole process of
learning a new language
addictively fun and easy and these
learning apps need to be fun now
they need to be everything's it's all
turned into a video game
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go
15-minute lessons that's manageable with
babel you can choose from 14 different
languages
including spanish french italian german
babel's speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent
right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of just
three go to babble
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
and use promo code theo
don't you want to babble in no no
new languages well you can that's
babel.com use promo code theo
thank you for supporting this podcast
also you know if you need help
no there's not always a way to get it
near you
you know i called up the other day i
finally called a friend and said hey i
need some help i need some help
amen it even it brought tears to my eyes
even saying it just saying it
voicing that into the world i need
help well better help
is there that's right better help
help you can start communicating with
them
quickly in under 48 hours there's a
broad range of therapists and counselors
available
which may not be locally available if
you live in the woods if you the
you know you the smith family robinson
or whatever
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
better help want you to start living a
happier life today
visit betterhelp.com theo
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help
they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states wow
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and this past weekend listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
theo i want to let you know that
a lot of shows on sale you can get
tickets theovonne.com tour
i think we might rock with the return of
the rat baby that's the tour name i'm
thinking of
and that feels kind of good and
and the rat is always returning you know
it
you know if you want a dose if you want
to set some cheese in the yard baby you
know
i'll be there and you know where to find
me
i'm upstairs gang
always we want to do something nice for
a single mom i want to thank our patreon
supporters as well we have a very small
patreon but we are very mighty
and i just feel grateful to be part of a
process of
just trying to think of somebody
different than myself and we got this
nomination video came in right here
hey theo this is remy i'm calling you
from ottawa canada
remy up there canadian and remy i'm not
sure if that's just part of a name or
not
maybe jeremy and i don't know what the
exchange rate is on names but
he'll i'll spot you a jer buddy if you
need one
that's what we do down here bye-bye
onward i want to nominate my friend
louise who's a single mom living in
slokan valley british columbia
she's got four kids two of them have
autism one who doesn't buddy you know
and i'm not saying that judgmentally
thank you for saying that
but everybody has it now i swear you
know you can't even meet it
you couldn't find nine people that don't
have autism if i gave you probably 14
minutes onward bubba thank you
the kids has cystic fibrosis and she
just pours
everything into these kids man she's
been homeschooling them since
before the pandemic she put so much work
into making sure they're
they're eating healthy and staying
active and uh
it's just been hard the last you know
year kind of watching her struggle with
the isolation of the pandemic and
we all are kind of struggling with
depression right now but it's just been
so
hard watching someone who works so hard
to make the life her kids happy
you know also kind of feel sad
and kind of isolated so i think i don't
know anyone who would deserve
the chance to just treat herself and do
something fun with her kids so
yeah man you're the best gang gang gang
brother thank you man
that's really sweet of you and everybody
is
everybody is having some effects from
this pandemic
from the isolation that's really the big
thing
more people are the effects from
the isolation from coven
and the separation
will are
are so much bigger than anything
i believe that this covet itself could
ever do
um but let's give a call to her let me
see if he said her name
hey theo this is remy i'm calling you
from ottawa canada
i want to nominate my friend louise
who's louise
and i'm from louisiana so that's a
perfect mix right there man
yeah let's see if we can't give a call
to louise right now
hey louise hi hey how are you
i'm good how are you good i'm not a
creep or anything i just
i am calling i work at a podcast my name
is theo
and i work at a podcast and
every so often we do we have people will
submit
a friend or someone they know who is a
single mom we do something for single
moms it's kind of nice
and you have a friend named remy who i
think just thinks that you're just
a special gal and really admires you
um so he submitted you for our single
mom nomination
yeah he told me it was a surprise he's
been very um
cryptic about this well we are a cryptic
bunch here at this podcast i will say
that
so that's pretty normal um
but he just said he really admires you
you know he said that you have
he said you do you do home school and
you have four children you guys home
schooled up there
yeah yeah we i i'm in uh bc southern bc
and i
homeschool my four kids and we we have
sheep and
ducks and we're pretty kind of living
off the
we're just kind of wild wild people yeah
that sounds pretty cool is it i bet the
kids love being around the animals huh
uh yeah like yeah not as much as i had
hoped i only just got to you but
we have always had like dogs i have a an
acreage so
the intention was when i bought it years
ago that we would
um well i thought i'd do more farming
but
then i kind of did the whole kid thing
and and now i
i do sort of an unschooled um
homeschooling so we don't do any like
set
classes per se they just
sort of run wild but in in like a
healthy awesome way
yeah wow that sounds awesome
do they you i live in nashville and
and i i'm in nashville right now
okay so we just operate out of nashville
and out of los angeles but um
but yeah sometimes i like it almost
sounds like summer camp does it feel
like that a little bit
yeah yeah it totally does we um people
come and hang out and
and they're sort of like they're like on
holiday and my kids are like but this is
every day
they're pretty much barefoot all the
time and
they just dig in the woods and it's so
interesting because we have i have
um my daughters they're almost 13 and so
she has friends
her one very close friends in toronto
her cousin and she goes to a
like a an academic very academic private
school
and they hang on the summer and you know
you wouldn't know one has gone to like
through the whole
super academic in how they converge or
how they talk i mean they know different
things sure but
my dog knows things that she doesn't
know and and she knows things that
mata doesn't know but you neither feel
like they know
less or more you know like they don't
know anything compared to the other
right yeah that sounds pretty
fascinating it's almost like an
experiment in some ways
that's what remy told me his phd and i
was like man i always wanted to do more
but
you know this is this is what i'm doing
now and he's like you're living the
experiment
yeah it sounds pretty magical i think
they must be really proud of you is it
is it uh it must be really does it feel
kind of empowering or does it feel
exhausting to have to be like the
teacher and the mom and everything kind
of
no i would say empowering i mean
sometimes it's it's a lot
sometimes but it's a lot i would say in
a good way especially as they get older
and you can really see
the things that i had hoped would happen
are happening you know when they're
toddlers and you're like god i hope this
is going to work out
i know and all these other people are
doing different things they're like i
don't know that's totally going to be
bad
because my kids don't they didn't learn
to read early
and and my daughter as i say now she's
13 and she's reading you know
all the big thick you know teen books
whatever from the libraries and
everything and
but she didn't learn to read until she
was 10 and the people that were just
breathing down
like she's not gonna learn to read and i
was like no i've done my research and
this is gonna work and
and she got she reads perfectly she
reads brilliantly and she has no baggage
about that she didn't learn to read when
she was
six or five or four or anything and
so it's it's it's empowering when it
works it it's kind of a little bit scary
when
when you're doing it and you're like
well i hope this is gonna work
yeah i bet dang that's cool though i'm
glad to see i'm glad to hear that it's
working out uh
it really sounds like yeah it sounds
like
um fun it is but you know it is it is
it's it is you have to i feel like to
really embrace it you have to be pretty
um just have fun with them like i kind
of just
they just kind of do what they want i
i'm not relaxed like and we live up near
a river so we go swimming all the time
like we walk over to the river and we
swim and you and i know my kids think
i'm really casual because
they don't wear life jackets and they
can all swim and they're swimming the
currents it's a strong current i mean
it's not why but it's
but the other day my one son he's eight
and he wasn't paying attention and he
just got swept a bit farther down
and then i was like get it and his
sister pulled him and it was
like it was fun i would have gone and
got him but he sort of was then
horrified that i kind of like
actually came down on him because most
of them i don't like i don't get that
we i i live by a philosophy we have very
few rules but the rules we have
are absolute you know you don't ever but
pretty much everything else you know
we're like you can bend on those things
right i don't
force many things but
it was kind of a wake-up call and then i
think he maybe was a little bit more
aware that i'm not
actually as casual as i appeared i think
well i think some people you know the
overprotective well yeah
it's a podcast please can you take
liverpool
[Music]
he's talking to me like i'm on a podcast
hey what's up
yeah okay hi nope
rebecca can you take libby i can't okay
i gotta walk here no worries
it's like a podcast guy he's talking to
me where do y'all live at
like what is it this isn't actually our
home
we're out of friends right now because
we live in well actually our home kind
of looks like this
we live in the kootenays in bc british
ponbia
but we're actually on our way to a
family cottage
um in ontario on the great lakes
dude you guys are gonna have a blast
that's cool i'm in transit
right now so you kind of caught us at a
funny time but we're actually
paused for the day to take a break
before we go on so
i don't know why so we're at a friend's
house for the day but their house is
actually
um we've never been here before but it's
surprisingly similar to ours
well it's a small world well we just
wanted to share with you that remy was
thinking about you and that we were
thinking about you we try to do
something nice to support single moms
uh just because we just think it's um
you know it's just such a it's a neat
position
and um so we wanted to send you a
thousand bucks it's just us dollars i
don't know if they're worth anything
but we seriously yeah we just wanted to
send it to you
so you could uh just go do something fun
with the kiddos um
oh my god really wow yep and that's it
there's no uh
there's no strings attached uh
um that's that's amazing uh and oh and
remy i'm supposed to be telling you that
remy
has a surprise for you because i tan
sheepskins
and he's going to send you a sheepskin
from me oh nice
from him y'all got some fresh sheep i
have some
yeah i have sheep and so that will kind
of be in the fall
okay oh i look forward to that we would
like to have a little bit of sheep in
here
yeah well sheepskin is the best it's
it's healthy and you can it keeps you
cool in the summer and hot in the winter
and
oh i'll eat off of it if it's nice
um i mean off the inside i'm not eating
off the hairy side but um
but anyway yeah we just wanted to let
you know that we were thinking about you
we're just always trying to
just be a part of um i don't know we're
just trying to be a part of people's
lives if we can in just kind of like a
simple way here and there and and so
that's it
we just wanted to let you know that remy
was thinking about you and now all of
our audience will be thinking about you
and it's really interesting to hear that
there's kind of this
this wild little family out there that's
just figuring it out in the world it's
really
i don't know it sounds exciting it is
exciting and
they're pretty they're pretty awesome
kids they're the most polite
when you meet them not so much at home
but they're they they got to figure it
out they're pretty cool
well i bet they're proud of you and we
are
um so thank you so much for your time
today and i hope you'll have a good day
yeah thank you okay louise you all be
safe in y'all's travels
okay thank you okay bye-bye bye
wow what a fascinating time you know
what a fascinating thing to be like
almost uh
we're just talking about smith family
robinson
and here they are you know
just interesting that people are doing
it people are figuring out ways
you know people are figuring out ways to
manage humans and sheep at the same time
and that's remarkable and it's inspiring
you know really listening to her and
just seeing kind of her little world
there is inspiring
um it's interesting
you know i think and those are the
things that i have to remember that are
going on
that people are just getting things done
and that there's a lot of cool
good stuff happening out in the world
and um and we have a photo here for kids
it's
really really adorable i think we can
get it into the episode as well so if
you're watching on the youtubes you can
see it
and they're doing well living
beautifully out there in the middle of
nowhere
it looks like or i don't know nowhere
but i mean
it's canada you know so it's i mean who
knows if it's real i think you almost
have to be
you know you have to take a flight out
of your dreams almost i feel like to get
there to some of these places but
anyhow remy thank you so much for the
submission and uh
thank you everybody for supporting the
podcast i got to get out of here i'm
going to get some nad in my arm i've got
this new they have a new
supplement type of thing it's not drug i
mean it's a natural chemical
which is an oxymoron of a statement
right there natural chemical
but i mean it's lysol that's what i'm
saying it's ivermectin it's uh
who knows what it is i don't know what
it is but i'm about to let them shoot it
in my arm for an hour
but anyway um just wanted to say thank
you guys for the support
thank you guys for being a part of this
past weekend
and uh i hope you'll be good to
yourselves because um
you deserve it we'll go out the way that
we came in man
listening to a little bit of bishop gun
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
blown
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it in my
but it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself go
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
and these rails that i've been riding on
they want so thin that they're damn
they're
now they just